tools for internal communication you're
like totally into these tools
very
interesting because before Sam we would
you know we had everything in our brains
and some of it on paper and now
everything's sort of becoming more
formalized so let's talk about
establishing these processes yeah when I
first joined the team I down at my desk
and I looked around and was like okay I
there's no slack nothing's set up how do
I communicate with with you Jason with
Ashley with Dumont I had no idea yeah
and I think you know when I asked each
team member I think when I asked you you
said oh well I use iMessage Ashley said
I'm s message Demond said email yeah
matt said google chat was like okay
first thing let's install slack I think
I wrote you like a three-page proposal
what that would look like what I was I
really wanted to use slack yeah and with
that yes I get everybody to invest and
everybody has to believe in slack yeah I
wasn't really into slack I found it so
disturbing all day long but now you love
it right well I'll tell you what I like
about it now is that I think it's making
everybody else communicate better I can
sort of pop in and out of it I don't
have to be a slave to it but I find it
highly distracting as a writer but yeah
yeah I think for everybody else that
works just wonderful yeah great
yeah and and before you were touching on
the slack integrations for the data
updates so right now we have we probably
up 15 installed so a couple of examples
of that is we have a Google Analytics
integration so every single morning we
get a report on how many people are
viewing are all of our different
websites and also how that's tracking
against previous weeks which is really
cool
I know segment has some integrations
utilizing zapier you know so and also I
have a feed coming in when someone
applies for a job via like LinkedIn so
we get the resume of the candidate and
information like that I also like that
we see like when somebody
signs up for an event or buys a ticket
or a sales lead comes in or we're
processing deals in our CRM we can kind
of see that stuff in real time it's it's
it's a nice way to sort of get
up-to-date on what's happening right now
yeah definitely
yeah and and to Ashley's point earlier
you don't have to be you know it limit
the communication that's required among
the team it's all you know more
proactive so you can just you know check
you don't have to be asking everyone on
the team like hey you know where are we
tracking against this what what's the
you know recent number for this you just
look in slack it's all there
best thing I would say is just to
utilize you know tools like asana for
checklists that's what we use as a team
for our production schedule also
utilizing tools like envision for
application design so you know you know
before envision it's really just okay
I'm gonna go into Photoshop or whatever
and design something and send it off but
envision has tools where you can you
know you know play with the designs in
real time and provide feedback and
things like that so envision is a tool I
would highly recommend for that yeah
I've read the checklist manifesto and
it's really great if you were doing
something over and over and over again
to make a template like if you're doing
a hundred episodes of this week in
startups or you're doing a hundred you
know investments a year you can really
start to go through your diligence list
or other items and make sure you don't
miss something because even doctors and
nurses and pilots and co-pilots
they were crashing planes and killing
people because they just didn't follow
the basic
checklists in fact they didn't have
checklist and when they instituted
checklists people stopped dying in
hospitals it also makes it easy for a
teammate you know team member to come in
and and help you they sure like a look
at your checklist and say know how to
either know how to do whatever your
process is or they can see what you
haven't checked yet and they can help
sure when you went on maternity we were
still able to do syndicates it wasn't
all locked in your head this is true
yeah